[Musik]
Schach man nennt es auch das Spiel der
Könige
Nico Georgiadis trägt den Titel
Schachgroßmeister als einer der besten
der Schweiz stellt er sich in Indien am
größten und bedeutendsten Schachturnier
der Welt seinen Kontrahenten
sie gemeint
ein Sport mental so fordernd nico ist
fast daran zerbrochen
wieso Schach ihn trotzdem immer wieder
mitreißt und was das Spiel mit ihm macht
davon handelt dieser Film
[Musik]
in wenigen Tagen geht das Abenteuer los
für Nico nichts Ungewöhnliches von klein
auf reist der heute 26-Jährige für seine
Lieblingsbeschäftigung das Schachspielen
um die Welt
diesmal geht's mit der
Nationalmannschaft nach
Chennai im Südosten von Indien ich freue
mich sicherlich auf in dich
Kultur wird aber ich freue mich auch
aufs Schachspieler
Nationalmannschaft
also dann gebe ich noch mal mehr als
überall freu mich wirklich viel mehr im
Vorfeld
Nico kenne ich schon von der Arbeit beim
SRF er ist für die Sendung Gesichter und
Geschichten als Videojournalist tätig
nico ist gewissenhaft aber im Büro fällt
der vor allem auf weil er laut ist und
chaotisch auf seine andere Welt bin ich
deshalb umso gespannter
Schach dieses strukturierte Spiel passt
nämlich so gar nicht zu ihm
[Applaus]
er sucht gerade seine Hose
oder sie ist
die meisten Schachspieler sind das
Problem
Gedanken verloren und
weniger konzentrierter eigentlich
das ist mega komische ja
Nikos Weg zum SRF finde ich speziell
2015 hat die Sendung G&G ein Porträt
über ihn als Schachprofi gemacht die
Arbeit des Journalisten hat in dermaßen
beeindruckt dass er auch zum Fernsehen
wollte so studierte er
publizistikwissenschaften und bewahrt
sich für ein Praktikum beim SRF diese
Zielstrebigkeit hat er wohl von seinem
Vater er war es auch der Nico zur
schachkarrierechte
das sind Vater mit Hund
[Gelächter]
ja also erstens ich sehe das
Nationalmannschaft
mehr
stört bzw
[Musik]
easy
zu seinen Eltern pflegt er ansonsten ein
enges Verhältnis deshalb will er sich
noch von ihnen verabschieden hier in
Schindellegi im Kanton Schwyz hat er bis
vor vier Jahren mit den Eltern und
seinen beiden jüngeren Schwestern
zusammengelegt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja schön
ja
mega schöne Brunch
Nicos Vater ist zielstrebig und
ehrgeizig er hat seinem Sohn das
königliche Spiel beigebracht schon
früher erkannte er Nikos Potenzial
sehr einfach durchlaufen aber am Nikos
ist Mango
und der
Sterne natürlich gemerkt
ist
und ich glaube das Bildgedächtnis Thema
hat im Schach muss man viele Züge
vorausdenken können und es braucht gute
Intuition
genauso hat der Vater auch Nicos
Karriere geplant als der kleine sechs
Jahre alt war meldete er ihn im
Schachclub an büffelte mit ihm
Schachbücher schickte ihn sogar für
mehrere Monate nach Spanien zur dortigen
Nummer eins
hat Nico irgendwie
ja extrem also vor allem wenn man ein
bisschen
laufen
wahrscheinlich aufgebaut wird
Druck macht sich eher wahrscheinlich am
meisten und ich würde sagen ich kann im
hoffentlich drucken
dieser harten Worte scheinen ihn nicht
zu beeindrucken
ohne Unterstützung
zum Großmeister geschafft dieser
international anerkannte Titel ist ein
Ritterschlag in der Schachwelt bisher
haben ihn in der Schweiz nur fünf
Personen erhalten Nico war damals 21
Jahre alt
danach fiel Nico in ein Loch Punkt
[Musik]
weiß natürlich
das Nico seinem Vater nichts davon
erzählt hat erstaunt nicht
bei der Arbeit scheut er nämlich keine
Konfrontation
[Musik]
nico ist wie immer knapp dran
die Schweiz schickt ein Frauen oder
Männerteam nach Indien pro Team sind es
fünf Spielerinnen oder fünf Spieler so
die Statuten mit dabei auch ein Captain
und ein Trainer
die beiden Teams reisen extra einen Tag
früher an um sich an Klima und Kultur zu
gewöhnen
Indien ist erstmals Austragungsort der
Schacholympiade ursprünglich wäre
Russland Gastgeberland gewesen doch dann
kam der Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
für Indien eine große Ehre zumal sich
das Land als Wiege des Schachs sieht
und 2000 Spielerinnen und Spieler aus
186 Nationen nehmen am größten und
wichtigsten Schachturnier der Welt teil
krass
leben rund 5 Millionen Menschen
es ist laut und hektisch nico hat das
zuvor noch nie erlebt
krass was für andere Welt ist da ist
also man hat sich größte
aber
wie gesagt die Straße
das ist so viel Menschen
funktioniert es
nicht gesehen so und ähm
[Musik]
Nikos Hotel ist vom ganzen Trubel
abgeschottet
das Turnier beginnt mit der
traditionellen Eröffnungsfeier
[Musik]
die Stadt hat sich für das
prestigeträchtige Turnier herausgeputzt
Chennai gilt schließlich als das Neckar
des Schachs in Indien
auf jeder Schach Werbung sind
Premierministerin der Regierungschef
dieses Bundesstaates im Süden zu sehen
beide werden an den Feierlichkeiten
erwartet
Nico wäre lieber im Hotel geblieben um
sich auszuruhen komisch ich erlebe ihn
immer als sehr unternehmungslustig
für dieses Turnier stehen laut Regierung
22.000 Sicherheitsleute im Einsatz
[Musik]
hey wir sind es ist so heiß es könnte
Region
[Musik]
2 Stunden 2 Stunde
die pompöse und sich irgendwann
wiederholende Show zieht sich in die
Länge
der Grund der Premierminister von Indien
nach renda Modi hat sich verspätet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also sehr gut
20 Minuten habe
die Schacholympiade ist offiziell
eröffnet
[Musik]
handlich handliches
Geduld ist auch im Job nicht Nikos
Stärke dafür darf er sich für einmal als
Star füllen
[Applaus]
die erste von insgesamt 11 schachrunden
steht an Nico beginnt den Tag so wie
immer vor einer Partie mit einem
speziellen Ritual
[Musik]
das Nico sehr sportlich ist Weißig wir
spielen ab und zu gegeneinander Tennis
er macht daraus immer einen Wettkampf
und regt sich über jedes verlorene Game
aus aber Turnübungen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
fit egal was passiert ist vorher das ist
eine Grund wieso ich das eigentlich
machen
[Applaus]
die tägliche Busfahrt wird zum neuen
Ritual
sich frei bewegen ist für alle
Schachspieler strikt verboten
die Regierung hat ein strenges
Sicherheitskonzept
[Musik]
gespielt wird in zwei unterschiedlichen
Hall
jeweils vier pro Mannschaft einer setzt
aus
Nikos Vater verfolgt die Partie online
von zu Hause aus
in der ersten Runde spielen die Männer
gegen Mauretanien punktemäßig ein
schwächerer Gegner die Schweiz hingegen
bewegt sich im vorderen Fünftel aller
Mannschaften das will aber nicht heißen
ein falscher Zug und die Partie kann
vorbei sein
[Musik]
im Saal herrscht striktes Rede und
Handyverbot
erlaubt sind hingegen das herumgehen und
der Gang zur Toilette
denn so eine Partie dauert meist über
vier Stunden
[Musik]
gewonnen
alles andere
Spiels erlebe ich Nico nie im Büro
ja und das das macht einfach das aus und
darum habe ich trotzdem gern
ein neuer Tag bricht an
nach einem zweiten Sieg steht nun in der
dritten Runde eine der stärksten Gegner
an Indien
[Musik]
der großgewachsene nico ist ein
beliebtes Fotos
sein Gegner der 16-Jährige dummerer
jogukesh schon mit 12 Jahren Großmeister
in dem Alter hatte Nico nicht nur Schach
im Kopf
aber
immer gerne
unterwegs
Großmeister
Training pro Woche und am Wochenende von
Schachturnier zu Schachturnier reisen
Nico gibt so schnell aber nicht auf in
Sachen Ehrgeiz steht ja seinem Vater
nichts nach
die ersten paar Schachzüge ist Nico am
Vormittag schon durchgegangen
[Musik]
am Tisch nebenan Magnus Carlsen der
amtierende Schachweltmeister aus
Norwegen
[Musik]
wer hat die bessere Nerven die bessere
Intuition wer denkt schneller
konzentriert sind jedenfalls beide
[Musik]
nicht einmal dass ich sie Filme stört
sie
[Musik]
doch gegen gokesh ist Nico chancenlos
[Gelächter]
der Vater wird es ihm noch persönlich
sagen sie stehen im Regen SMS Kontakt
die Teamkollegen wissen wie hart Nico
eine Niederlage trifft
am besten lassen wir das mal in Ruhe und
dann kommt sowas
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wenn er sich schon im Tennis wegen eines
verlorenen Games so aufregt wie muss es
sich jetzt für ihn anfühlen
dass er eine Runde aussetzt sagt
jedenfalls schon alles
stattdessen will er mit seiner
Teamkollegin Tami zu den Tempelanlagen
ganz in der Nähe
weil sie nicht im turnierbus reisen muss
ein Polizist mit
[Musik]
ist es üblich dass Polizisten die
Hotelgäste begleiten oder ist es wegen
des Turniers
nur wegen des Turniers ist es sonst
gefährlich oder geht es um extra
Sicherheit
extra Sicherheit
du kennst Nico seit der neun Jahre alt
ist Viva er damals
er war sehr schüchtern er war sehr nett
aber sehr schüchtern er hat nicht viel
gesagt
vielleicht weil ich Französisch sprach
und ihr Deutsch und sein Englisch war
nicht so gut
wir haben nur gelächelt gelacht er war
einige Jahre so schüchtern dann hat es
sich geändert
mich selbst damals nicht als schüchtern
vielleicht war es mit uns
vielleicht mit Mädchen
als ich ein Kind war hatte ich Angst vor
ihnen
hast du immer noch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sie macht mich neugierig darüber will
ich später mehr erfahren zuerst aber zu
den Tempeln
der Tempelbezirk von Mama la puram
gehört zu den wichtigsten
archäologischen Fundorten Südindiens und
gehört heute zum UNESCO Weltkulturerbe
kannte
[Musik]
für ein gutes Spiel du gewinnst
[Gelächter]
sie braucht rot
nein hier hat kein rot
sie gewinnt sie gewinnt das Schauspiel
keine Probleme
[Gelächter]
ich bin überrascht es sei Nikos erster
Ausflug an einem Schachturnier ich
erlebe ihn eigentlich als neugierigen
und Interessierten Journalisten ich bin
dass sie gut spielen als dass sie dann
nur gesehen
schaut dass man das so schnell machen
kann
[Applaus]
du hast gegen Google gespielt gestern ja
wie alt ist der 16 er hat gewonnen
er hat mich auseinander genommen ich mag
dein fieses lachen die zwei brechen den
Ausflug irgendwann ab Schach hat
Priorität
auch die nächsten Tage sind streng die
Bilanz der Schweizer Mannschaft
durchzogen
jeden Morgen bleibt ihr sonst so
gesellige Nico auf seinem Zimmer allein
er übt das sogenannte Eröffnungsspiel
das heißt er geht die ersten paar
Schachzüge der jeweiligen Partie durch
und erhofft sich dadurch einen Vorteil
sehr oft allein und trainiere und ja
auch alle einsam und das genau darum
wieso ich mich
zu einerseits
muss man
lange weiter trainieren
Energieverteilung
[Applaus]
Nikos Leben verläuft geradlinig was er
anpackt gelingt so zumindest nehme ich
es wahr doch wo stößt auch er an seine
Grenzen ich bin mega orange
[Musik]
wieso oder oder keine Gras und ich weiß
dass ich das selber
die Frage wieso ist das so und äh hast
was kann ich sagen
andere Menschen auch und oder
gefragt ich kann
Filme
ich mir sehr viel Gedanken ständig über
alle meine Sachen machen
Gedanken die jetzt in den Hintergrund
geraten die elfte und letzte Partie
steht an
ich sehe genau das
die Gegner heute Israel
von der Bewertung her sind sie ähnlich
stark
gewonnen
sein Vater saß ihm während dieser vier
Stunden auch heute im Nacken wenn auch
aus der Ferne also ich bin sehr sicher
er so wie ich wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gut
der letzte Abend bricht an
die offizielle Siegesfeier Schwänzen sie
die Schweiz hat es nur auf Platz 51
geschafft Gold geht an Usbekistan
[Applaus]
verlieren
genau
sie hatten sich nicht den Sieg erhofft
aber doch etwas mehr dennoch wird die
Reise in guter Erinnerung bleiben
nico hat mich nicht nur nach Indien er
hat mich auf eine Reise in seine Welt
mitgenommen je länger das Turnier
dauerte desto mehr hat er mir vor Augen
geführt schach ist nicht nur das Spiel
der Könige es ist nikospiel
[Musik]